hi I'm Victoria and I am a sophomore
double math and physics major my name is
Jessica math has many applications one
of which is physics and understanding
physics helps me state when you're
little you know about fiction and you
know what forces but you don't know
exactly how it's applied when I started
learning about physics it was really
interesting
skating is pretty much all physics when
I'm starting the spin I would start with
my arms out and then slowly bring my
arms in and this increases the speed
because I'm decreasing my moment of
inertia and because of the mathematical
equations that lie behind this
I am also increasing my angular velocity
and therefore spinning a lot faster my
favorite jump is probably the axle
because you have to use an edge and to
like change from linear velocity to
angular velocity and like turn in the
air and get enough turns and land on one
foot
people who study math and physics by
using sensors to like detect your body
can model your body in the air and how
you turn like everything leading up to
the jump while you're in the air and how
you land and they will tell you when you
have to take off from the ground like if
there's a specific angle you have to
take off from or how tight you have to
be they figured out that skaters land
with a force impact about eight times
their body weight the Figure Skating
Club is relatively new on campus it was
created by two members who are now
seniors this spring in March we're going
to host the Carnegie cup which is our
first time hosting an intercollegiate
competition we're going to be hosting it
at Lemieux which is the official
Penguins practice arena and then there's
going to be about 25 to 30 teams there
to compete